I see a darkness in you and in that
darkness eyes staring back at me brown
eyes blue eyes green eyes eyes you'll
shut forever
we will meet again
I can become someone else speak in their
voice live in their skin
I could even become you
hey everybody a lot of you been
requesting a melisandre video so there
are a couple different prophecies that
she's given that she's coming back in
season 8 like she said I have to die in
this strange land I'll address that but
the more interesting one is the fact
that earlier she actually told Aria that
they would meet again - meaning that she
will be back at Winterfell in season 8
one of the really cool things is is that
when she tells her that prophecy about
the different eyes she sees staring back
at her from the darkness they've
actually already fulfilled that part of
the prophecy so I'll explain how they
fulfilled that but if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'm doing Game of Thrones videos till
season 8 gets here there's a bunch of
prequel news to that I'll explain at the
end of the video but to start with the
fulfillment of her prophecy when
Melisandre says that there are eyes that
you'll shut forever she's talking about
Arya becoming a faceless person so
that's what she saw she was seeing Arya
wearing the different faces and that's
what the different eye colors were for
so she's already killed all three of
those people blue eyes brown eyes and
green eyes the brown eyes are for the
little girl's face that she wears before
she kills Meryn Trant remember that
actually led to her being blinded by a
jaqen H'ghar
[Music]
the next ones are a little bit out of
order I'll explain why this is I think
you know they were teeing up their big
twists and they kind of knew how it
would go down but they didn't know
exactly when it would happen the next
face that she wears winds up being the
green eyes that Melisandre mentions and
that's Walder Frey David Bradley has
green eyes when people ask you what
happened here tells me the north from
Memphis then even though she doesn't
wear anyone elses face before the end of
season seven she kills Littlefinger in
what color are Aden Gillan's eyes
they're actually blue so I think that's
a bit of a hat tip that she might wind
up wearing little fingers face during
season eight at some point maybe in some
bid to do something with Circe there's a
lot of big questions about how she's
going to reach her downfall but the real
problem with wearing little fingers face
is that there were so many people in
that room that watched him get killed
that the word that he's dead is going to
get out so it's gonna be a lot harder to
fool people when you wear his face so if
she gets wind of that via her little
birds and then Aria shows up trying to
pretend to be Littlefinger Cersei will
know that something's up no matter how
good arias skills are but the other
important thing here is that she says
that we will meet again so she's going
to come to Winterfell because that's
where Arya is going to be for most of
the season they're gonna have that big
star / Union in the early episodes in
Melisandre already told Varys that she
would be going back to the east but she
would return I have to die in this
strange land
so she's dropping a couple big bombs and
doing a bit of foreshadowing one that
she's foretelling her death I have to
die in this strange land so way back
here during season three when she's
seeing this she looks a little bit
surprised but you know whatever's
happened since then she's made her peace
with it I think she's just happy that
she's brought Fire and Ice together and
Jon Snow and Daenerys have been united
so she probably feels like she's done
the biggest part of her job and now it's
just gonna be bringing in reinforcements
so even though Melisandre isn't an
antagonist in Arya isn't a stone-cold
serial killer I still believe that she's
going to meet her end at arias hand but
a lot of that just gets tied up in how
you think that Arya's character is going
to wind up
because the idea that she's going to
have a reunion with Gendry she's gonna
see Jon Snow again
she's formed the Wolfpack with her
sister so she actually seems fairly
well-adjusted even though she has all
these crazy skills I still think she has
some of that darkness in her I see
darkness in you so Melisandre wasn't
lying and that didn't go away just
because she formed the Wolfpack with
Sansa so if you're worried about Arya
getting a soap-opera
ending I just I feel like there'll be a
couple left turns for her character even
though the main narrative is all about
taking down the night king in ending the
war for the dawn there needs to be a
satisfying conclusion for all the
characters in Melisandre's character has
been so tied up and fulfilling all these
prophecies killing people left and right
in the name of that making all kinds of
mistakes Shireen is the reason that Jon
Snow banished her from his presence I
didn't end things well with the king in
the north
so she's killed a lot of people she's on
Arya [ __ ] list she's on Davos as
shitless she's on Jon's [ __ ] list she's
on Brienne's [ __ ] list
too because she's the one that birthed
the shadow baby they killed Renly so
then you have to assume that she's going
to have some sort of comeuppance for
that what has been her reckoning her
reckoning should be Arya staring back at
her from the darkness wearing someone
else's face so in this moment here when
she says I see eyes staring back at me
and says all the different colors I
think that that will turn into a literal
thing on the TV show so it's more of a
metaphorical thing when she's speaking
about it here because she's watching a
vision of her in all these different
places in Westeros in the east and then
as she's foreseen her own death
happening in season 8 the eyes that she
shuts forever will also belong to
Melisandre but that doesn't even get
into the idea of how Melisandre is going
to help them with the war for the dawn
in season 8 there's still a lot of
things that she could bring to bear
through the red priests so the red
temples are really big thing in Essos
The Hound always made a lot of jokes
about fire worshippers how there's not a
lot of them in Westeros the primary
faith in Westeros is the faith of the
seven but over in the east they're in
the majority so they have many red
temples with many red priests with many
warriors they have a warrior caste they
also have something called the fiery
hand which is sort of their version of
the unsullied they're not cut like the
unsullied are but they're still a badass
by
force that they used to defend the red
temples so Melisandre could bring Kimbra
and the other red priests with a bunch
of the fiery hand to help bolster their
forces up at Winterfell so in the way
that you have the Dragons fire fighting
ice literally fighting Viserion
breathing what looks like ice but it's
actually just blue fire you can also
have a sea of red soldiers fighting the
blue soldiers the whites of the night
King so it's all about Fire and Ice
there's always a lot of metaphors and
Game of Thrones don't be surprised that
the TV show uses a lot of visual
metaphors in addition to that so that's
also probably one of the reasons why
they chose Viserion to look like this
visually give him blue fire because you
have the green fire for Cersei because
it's wildfire you have the regular red
looking fire of the regular dragons then
you have vissarion's blue fire so just
let me know in the comments how do you
think that Melisandre is going to die in
the final season do you think that'll be
Arya to do the deed and do you think
that she's actually going to come back
with kin vara in the other red priests
when she returns to Westeros returns to
die as she tells Varys but what will
happen next is as I was planning on
doing a Daenerys video because Emilia
Clarke just dyed her hair blonde which
is a big change from what she's done in
previous seasons it's just a highlight
of her commitment to the character and
there are a lot of theories about what
that means for Daenerys as character
changes in season 8 so I'll address that
when I post that video but the cool
thing is is they just confirmed that
there really was a fifth game of Thrones
prequel that they're developing there
used to just be four and what they're
doing is is they're developing pilot
scripts for all them and they're just
gonna pick the strongest one and that
will be the prequel series that'll run
after the main show ends so the one they
just confirmed is actually being led by
Bryan cogman who was a writer for a long
time on Game of Thrones he was actually
known as the keeper of the continuity
within sort of like the writers circle
with Dan and Dave like they all study
the books a lot but of all of them Bryan
cogman was the one who was the deepest
into it so of all the people that worked
on Game of Thrones the main series he
probably has the most book knowledge so
even though ancient Valyria the Hundred
Years of Blood the Blackfyre rebellion
the War of the ninepenny kings all you
know big conflicts that they could use
as the backbone of whatever prequel
they're going to do I'm just really
interested to see what he's actually
doing I think I've already talked about
how they said that it's not gonna be
Robert's rebellion and it's not gonna be
the tales of Dunkin egg but pretty much
anything else is up for grabs and even
though Aegon's conquest would be really
awesome to do that's kind of what the
main show is doing right now there's so
many parallels with Daenerys as
character that I don't know that they
would immediately jump to that so new
Game of Thrones posting later this week
congratulations to Ruben Aguilar you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
click here to watch that brand new
punisher trailer it's a totally badass
and you can click here to watch that
animated Targaryen prequel video again
thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight